this is just like the only time the only
cereal I would ever see this would make
sense where you put the milk in first
would be grape nuts because they sink
you know what I mean and then it's like
but why are you deciding that milk is
the that cereal is a variable you always
put in how much cereal you want and then
you put the abdominal milk based on the
amount of cereal thank you you don't
pour the milk and put the amount of
cereal based on the amount of milk
that's Insanity it makes no sense at all
it's all going to get to the it floats
anyway it's it's ridiculous to me to
pour milk into an empty bowl oh they did
pull it and how many people have 42 000.
it's 93.5 more to the cereal first so
there are people out there six people
out of every hundred that pour milk into
a bowl and then pour their cereal why I
don't I I think just to be different
maybe like who first of all that's
passed down
yeah and if that's changed it's because
of it's uh it's nurture it's not nature